this video is made possible by shaker
and spoon shaker and spoon send out a
cocktail box each month with the
ingredients needed to make bar quality
cocktails in your own home yet $20 off
your first box by going to shaker in
spoon comm /by a graphics there's a link
below
Bassam Mao Zedong was a much-loved
revolutionary hero who saved China from
the rule of foreign aggressors he
modernize China by bringing the wonders
of Western industrialization to their
Shores to others though he is remembered
for being a sociopathic tyrant who
sacrificed the lives of millions of
people in order to bring his political
experiment to life in the video today
the life of the Chairman
[Music]
a farmer and landowner named Mao you
Chang was a self-made man he was born
into poverty but he worked hard and
saved enough to buy two acres of rice
paddies over the years he employed
workers do tens the land for him and
most of his profits went back into
expanding his farm he builds a
comfortable life for his wife when she
may and their future children sadly his
wife had difficulty getting pregnant and
she lost her first two children during
infancy she gave birth to her only child
Mao Zedong in 1883 growing up Mao Zedong
lived very comfortable life compared to
his peers it was not uncommon for
Chinese children to walk around without
shoes and wear clothes that were in
tatters they barely had enough food to
eat ins they could not afford proper
health care the fact that Mouser Dongs
parents could afford to provide all of
the basic necessities for their child is
why some people considered them to be
wealthy
the one thing that Mao Zedong had in
common with all other children in China
though was that he was taught the
religion and philosophy of Confucianism
one of his most well known teachings is
that everyone should try to go with the
flow and balance the energy of yin and
yang when it came to the government
confucius said that people should try to
be satisfied with their lot in life and
they should know their place in order
for society to run smoothly confucius
said there is government when the prince
is Prince and the minister is minister
when the father is father and the son is
son however Mao Zedong did not agree
with everything Confucius taught after
all he knew from firsthand experience
that his father was able to work his way
out of poverty he wanted to believe that
he could grow up to be more than just a
farmer's son in school Mao Zedong was
one of the top students in his class and
he loved reading as many books as he
could get his hands on
but at 13 years old his parents they
removed him from his elementary school
in order to help his father work on the
farm his father tried to arrange a
marriage with a young girl named Luo Yi
GU who was the daughter of a nearby
farmer and landowner this would have
ended his education and completely
sealed his fate so he refused to marry
her at 16 years of age he convinced his
parents that he
wanted to be an intellectual and his
parents agreed to send him to a boarding
school in the city of Changsha when he
was in this city he met other
like-minded people who believed that
there was a need to change the Chinese
Way of life in the eighteen hundred's
China was seeing more and more trade
from Western countries from 1840 to 1840
to China and Great Britain they had a
big conflict known as the opium wars and
trying to lost after signing the Treaty
of Nanking Hong Kong became a British
territory and European traders now had
access to Chinese ports even though this
was a peace treaty the Chinese people
nicknames this the unequal treaties
because it appeared as though the Ching
dynasty was bowing to the demands of
Great Britain China was far from being
an industrialized nation their
technology was so far behind the rest of
the world it was far too easy for
Western countries to take advantage in
1895 Japan attempted to overpower China
and their influence over Korea and this
was known as the first sino-japanese war
the cherry on top of an already bad
situation came in the year 1908 when the
Emperor passed away and the only male
heir to the Ching dynasty was a
two-year-old named Phu you it's not a
surprise that people began to lose their
faith in the strength of the dynasty in
1911 Mao Zedong was eighteen-years-old
the Xinhai revolution happens and the
People's Republic of China brought an
end to the Ching dynasty
[Music]
after switching to the People's Republic
the overarching government was called
the Kuomintang also known as the
Nationalist Party or the KMT the
Kuomintang allowed warlords to rule over
their perspective territories across
China each warlord had the power to
create their own laws charge taxes and
raise their own armies as a university
student Mao Zedong's favorite subject
was philosophy he read The Wealth of
Nations by Adam Smith and the spirit of
laws by Montesquieu he also read all of
the works of the Chinese revolutionaries
who were behind the People's Republic
during this time he created the
Association for student self-government
and said Hunan first Normal University
so that students could have a voice to
protest against the school rules he also
formed a student volunteer army the
group had around 80 members and they all
shared their ideas on government and
philosophy it was during this time that
Mao Zedong was introduced to the work of
Karl Marx out of all the political
philosophies they studied he and his
friends agreed with the ideas of
communism and this was because it
promised that every person in society
would have their basic needs met Mao
Zedong continued to excel in school and
he was number three in his graduating
class he got a job at Beijing University
as a librarian where he was able to read
as many books as his heart desired the
Communist Party of China or CCP was
established in 1921 one of the founders
leaders how was a librarian at Peking
University
the other was Chen duk-soo who was an
intellectual who had been a part of
establishing the People's Republic of
China after seeing how China adjusted to
the new Republic duk-soo believed that
the Warlord's were taking advantage of
the peasant class and that the political
system needed adjusting he thought
communism would actually be better for
their society Mao Zedong was just 28
years old at the time and he was one of
the many young people who began
attending communist meetings after work
once people began to learn about the
teachings of Karl Marx the Communist
Party of China gains a huge following
many peasant people were unhappy with
their respective warlords and they
wanted a new system of government of
course communism was posing a huge
threat to the nationalist party unlike
the rest of the parties in the Republic
communism actually had the potential to
spread across the entire country and
replace them as the leading party
they believed it was time to get rid of
the Communists in China before they
gains too much power in 1927 a gang
working for the KMT attacked and killed
members of the Communist Party they
announced the plan to eradicate every
single member of the CCP this event is
remembered as the Shanghai massacre roar
the April the 12th purge over 300,000
communists were killed and 50,000 people
denounced their party affiliation out of
fear the shanghai massacre is credited
for starting the chinese civil war since
the KMT was the original Party of the
Republic of China they felt that it was
time for them to eliminate the feudal
system of warlords
and the Communists as well in order to
unite all of China under one government
[Music]
in 1931 when Mao Zedong was 48 years old
he was elected as the chairman of the
Communist Party in 1934 the Chinese
civil war was still raging on Mao Zedong
led the members of the Communist Party
and what is remembered as the long march
they trekked over 4,000 miles through
mainland China in their attempts to fend
off KMT forces the leader of the
Nationalist Party chyann kai-shek was
sending troops after the Communists and
he ran several campaigns in his attempt
to defeat them Mao Zedong did not have
an army as large as the KMT but he had
his charisma wherever they went
he used his power of persuasion to tell
the villagers that communism would
improve their lives he promised them
that they would never go hungry again
people were so unhappy living under the
rule of their warlords that it wasn't
very hard to convince people to fight
for the cause after losing thousands of
men in battles that dawn would just
restock his army with new peasants in
the next village and just keep on
marching forward in 1937 all of China
would have to hit pause on their Civil
War because Japan was taking advantage
of the chaos by invading Manchuria this
was known as the second sino-japanese
war for years Japan had attempted to
take over Chinese territories the
Japanese they tortured they killed they
raped Chinese civilians everywhere and
they went and decimated the Chinese
major cities the armies of the Warlord's
and the KMT they were already weakened
from the
as they sustained while fighting each
other there was no way they could fend
off the Japanese Empire on their own the
leader of the KMT Chiang kai-shek had to
swallow his pride and ask the Communist
Party for help their red army was
growing in numbers they defended China
against the Japanese in what is known as
the hundred regiments offensive the Red
Army was largely made up of peasants who
didn't have time for proper military
training so Mao Zedong used guerrilla
warfare tactics they also called in some
help of the USSR who closed in on
Japanese occupied Manchuria from the
side while China was on the other they
succeeded in saving the country however
once the Japanese were gone the civil
war it was back in 1946 Mao Zedong in
his Red Army defeated the KMT and became
the new rulers of China at this point
people fought Mao Zedong was a national
hero and the rightful leader of their
country not only did he save them from
the Japanese but he also unified the
country under one rule for the first
time since the Qin Dynasty people were
hopeful that things would finally start
to change for the better but actually
they were gonna get a whole lot worse
[Music]
in 1958 Mao Zedong officially began his
plan this was called the Great Leap
Forward this was his attempt to use
communist ideals to bring modern
industrialization to China he might have
had the best intentions at heart but no
matter how many books one may read about
creating a new society there is a huge
difference between theory and actually
doing something in real life the Great
Leap Forward created a major land reform
where citizens were no longer allowed to
own private property farmers had to give
up their land to the greater good of the
public they still had to work but they
were not allowed to keep the food they
were growing because the rules dictated
that people who were far more important
to society deserved nourishment first
and that the peasants could be fed with
whatever was left over he sent medical
services to all Chinese villagers
ensuring that all the citizens had
health care and they were fit enough to
do manual labor he commanded many of the
people of China to start constructing
factories and new governmental buildings
most peasants were farmers their entire
lives and then no idea how to work in a
factory still though they were expected
to produce steel and other
industrialized materials there were so
many people now working in factories it
was impossible to properly train or
manage everyone despite having a lot of
issues getting adjusted to the new
policy the plan it actually worked for a
very short window of time crop
production went up and people we're
healthy errands had more food to eat
than ever before despite the setbacks
the Chinese people were also able to
erect a few modern buildings this
progress it all came crashing down in
less than a year though this happened in
the winter of 1959 Mao Zedong had
suggested that farmers grow more grain
and this was stored in silos however
without growing other types of food to
store for the winter months it remember
people were expected to survive only on
bread in the winter the weather that
year it was awful as well they
experienced widespread droughts followed
by massive typhoons that caused flooding
that destroyed crops tigers leopards and
wolves were attacking farmers as they
tried to cultivate more land their
fourth now created an anti pest campaign
where he encouraged people to shoot
these animals on sight and eat their
meat this pushed tigers and leopards
near extinction and people killed 70
five percent of their population the
Great Leap Forward was actually a huge
step backwards for China and it created
a widespread famine that killed millions
of people people resorted to eating
household pets like dogs and cats just
in order to survive some even resorted
to cannibalism in 1959 he was so
unpopular that he had to step down as
the chairman of the Communist Party and
he handed over his position as state
chairman to a more moderate party
representative the Xiao cui however now
Zidane continued to work in a leading
position in the government and tried to
run his Great Leap Forward from behind
the scenes instead of recognizing that
his policy was doomed to fail Mao Zedong
was convinced that this was just bad
luck and pressed the people to keep
going however people just continued to
die year after year
finally in 1961 the Great Leap Forward
it was canceled by the time he finally
ended the policy 36 million people had
died
[Music]
you'd think that after being responsible
for the deaths of millions of people and
somehow not being killed for it
you know it was time to quit but in 1966
Mao Zedong trying to regain the trust of
the people and become state chairman
once again he has a place to blame for
his mistakes somewhere else he claimed
that the bourgeoisie the top 1% of
society were ruining everything and that
now himself he was on the side of the
peasants he builds up a cult of
personality and people they strongly
supported him again because well they
remembered him as a revolutionary hero
who saved their country from the
Japanese and provided them with food
rations and free health care his
followers they were willing to do
whatever he asked he knew from his days
as a college student that young people
were perfect for molding into
revolutionaries he convinced a group of
students called the Red Guard to seek
out anyone who was speaking out against
the Communist Party he encouraged them
to even murder their professors who
spoke against Mao's policies just in
order to make an example of them
according to some accounts Mao's Red
Guards were so savage they partook in
flesh banquets or ritualistic
cannibalism of their enemies Mao Zedong
called the USSR and North Korea traitor
revisionist who were bastardizing the
original work of calm Marx his
interpretation of communism was so
different from the rest of the world
that many people called his philosophy
maoism instead of isolating his people
from the outside world like other
communist nations he encouraged
globalization and open trade which is
why China's economy eventually rebounded
and indeed this actually set the stage
for the economic strength that China has
today in 1968 the Minister of Pakistan
brought a gift of 14 mangoes to Chairman
Mao people of China never eaten tropical
fruit before so this was a delicacy to
them now couldn't possibly forty mangoes
on his own so he handed out the fruit to
his political team and a couple got in
the hands of a group of factory workers
they were so mesmerized by this magical
sweet fruit that they literally started
to worship it saying that it was a
symbol of the wonderful new things the
Chairman Mao would bring to their land
they placed it in a glass case and when
the fruit went bad they replaced it with
a wax replica one man who had
never tried mango before questioned why
everyone was worshipping this piece of
fruit he tried to compare it to a sweet
potato he simply couldn't believe that
mangos could taste so great well then it
got a little bit ridiculous because even
the mere suggestion that a mango wasn't
a magical fruit was enough to kill a man
for treason this is just one of many
examples of how irrationally devoted to
Mao Zedong people were in the in 1970
when the country was running low on
building supplies Mao Zedong ordered his
workers to tear down the Great Wall of
China in order to use the bricks to
build new houses and of dam he also
destroyed ancient artwork or anything
else that was considered to be a symbol
of the bourgeoisie he was willing to
dismantle thousands of years of Chinese
history and culture in order to execute
his communist vision
[Music]
when he was getting older Mao Zedong was
shameless when it came to reaping the
benefits of being a communist dictator
he almost never bathed or brushed his
teeth and claims that he cleansed
himself inside the bodies of his
mistresses not surprisingly he
contracted sexually transmitted
infections and spread them to several
women who actually wore their illness as
something of a badge of honor since it
was given to them by Chairman Mao yep
when he was in his sixties he appointed
a sixteen-year-old girl named Jiang Yu
Feng to be his personal secretary she
spent so much time with him that even
Mao Zedong's wife had to go through
Jiang you thing first before she could
make an appointment and speak with her
husband in 1973 he was sitting in a
trade meeting with Henry Kissinger and
he reportedly offered to trade 10
million Chinese women to the United
States he said that women caused too
many problems and that it would be
better to just get rid of them
in 1974 his third wife the beautiful
actress jiying Jing decided that she
would not sit around waiting for
husband's respect and affection she
began gathering her own collection of
young male lovers she got so bold she
would even allow her boyfriends to show
up at the house and now never protested
against her affairs
when he died in 1976 people they were
devastated he was buried in a crystal
casket so that people could see his body
when they came to visit lines of people
queued up to pay their respects and many
of them openly cried when they saw the
body of their Dear Leader even to this
day the memory of Mao Zedong is revered
by many as they remember him as one of
the great heroes of the nation but love
him or hate him
China would be a very different place
today if it was not for Mao Zedong maybe
without him China would have never
become a leading economic powerhouse but
maybe without him millions of people
would not have died so chairman now not
exactly the chariot of subjects that you
know what can take the edge off his
communist ways well a cocktail and
that's convenient because today's video
is brought to you by shaker and spoon
now I'm not gonna mix up some cocktails
at work because I'm not Don Draper so
let's through the magic of television
travel Hyman hello welcome to my home
let's make some cocktails
so with shaker and spoon you get three
cocktails then you get to have a cracker
this month they are the spice of life
tea and honey and the mighty Creek
cobbler now I believe Beckett's then
Smee is one of these dehydrated Mandarin
wheels so I'm gonna make this it's also
with Irish whiskey and I have a lot of
Irish whiskey on hand so that's a good
thing first step I need to crush some
ice
[Applause]
now with shaker and spoon it's available
in the US obviously I'm not there so
they make special accommodations and
send me the stuff internationally which
I really appreciate they normally ship
the fruit with them I had to buy my own
orange but don't worry everything you
need except for the booze comes in the
box
I also worry this orange is absolutely
massive it might not actually fit in my
glass this is a fine-looking orange good
news I might not need to put them in the
glass I should read the recipe dress
first before I start with these things
that they do big Evo my shaker this is a
ridiculously huge orange I'm just gonna
cut them in half and put them in like
that because apparently my local shop
sells mutant oranges one and a half
ounces of orange spiced syrup this is it
got myself one of these I always feel
like a such a bartender we like and it
makes that that nice ringing sound so
pop that in there pop that in there got
a muddle about for six seconds you know
what's cool if you don't know what
muddling is it tells you right here
using a muddler press fruits or herbs
into the bottom of the glass usually
with added sugar or syrup
when muddling be careful not to destroy
the fruits or herbs you want to release
their oil and flavor not pulverize I
don't have a muddler I'm pretty sure
they sent me a
I think I lost it I'm sorry today we're
using some Tullamore do that in there
you have that all in there crane
oh yeah garnish with one of these bad
boys oh my god
it is super good thank you shaker and
spoon I I'm sure you can all understand
why this probably one of my favorite
sponsorships you know lots of useful
stuff but this is the fun stuff you get
$20 off your first box with shaker and
spoon see on a link in the description
below to do that as always thank you for
watching thanks for shaker and spoon
back to the studio oh that is shaker and
spoon and you can get $20 off your first
box by going to shaker and spoon comm
slash biographic thanks to shaker and
spoon for the sponsorship and thanks to
you for watching
[Music]